la terre est ronde oui on a tous vu
boulot l'heure on a tous vu les images
satellite de la terre on n'a sans doute
pas mal d'entre ont pris l'avion est
observée de nous mêmes la rotondité de
la terre
mais à l'époque des grecs comment
aurait-il pu savoir eux que la terre
était ronde et surtout comment aurait-il
pu le calcul et avec les moyens de
l'époque le rayon de la terre mais aussi
incroyable que cela puisse paraître ils
y sont arrivés avec des méthodes assez
assez sophistiqué méthodes dont j'ai le
plus entendu parler basse et regarder un
bateau partir au loin et passer sous
l'horizon est en fait il est possible en
regardant à quel point le bateau va sous
l'horizon de calculer rotondité de la
terre si on connaît bien le bateau et si
on fait quelques mesures sur la distance
qui le sépare du bateau et ça je trouve
vraiment assez incroyable on va essayer
de voir un petit peu les mathématiques
qui sont derrière ça prenons un peu de
recul
regardons la terre en entier supposons
que le bateau soit quelque part sur
terre et qu'on le voit à l'horizon alors
née à gauche
donc si on voit un point du bateau
qu'est exactement à l'horizon c'est que
l'angle de viser vers ce point bas est
perpendiculaire à la verticale paramus
c'est à dire la droite qui passe par
nous et le centre de la terre on obtient
alors un triangle rectangle dont
l'hypoténuse va être égal au rayon de la
terre plus la hauteur du bateau qui est
sous l'horizon et dont les côtés sont la
distance qui sépare du bateau et le
rayon de la terre
utilisant le théorème de pythagore se
rend compte que la hauteur immergé plus
le royaume de la terre le taux de carie
est égale distance du bateau au carré
plus le rythme de la terre au carré donc
si on maintenant développe la partie à
gauche c'est cette équation avec une
identité remarquable on obtient m² + 2
et rajpath achkhar et égale d'écart et
plus et recari maintenant on peut
simplifier des deux côtés par air carré
nous tient deux étages plus acheteur est
égal à des carrés maintenant on va
utiliser un développement limité qu'en
est-il de développement limité qu'on a
vu dans l'épisode précédent pour
négliger la woerth acheter rec qui va
être beaucoup plus petite que 2 et
râches n'obtient alors l'approximation
de 0h à peu près égale à des carrés ce
qui signifie que air est à peu près
égale à des carrés sur deux âges et ça
ça veut dire que si on connaît la
distance du bateau et la hauteur
immergée du bateau on est capable de
calculer le rayon de l'alter il calcule
que je vous ai donné s'ils sont un peu
approximatif pour voir des calculs plus
rigoureuse vous invite à voir
l'excellent blog de son septennat
il a fait un billet à ce sujet donc ça
veut dire que si on connaît le bateau à
la base on peut mesurer la hauteur du
bateau on voit localiser le milieu du
bateau ont un gros point au milieu de
photos puis on la sauve à tous partir
lorsque la partie créonnais du bateau
passe juste au niveau de l'horizon on
saura alors exactement la longueur de la
partie du bateau qui est sous l'horizon
il restera alors plus qu'à calculer à
distance au bateau mais si on connaît la
longueur de la partie du bateau quiche
au dessus de l'horizon
on peut essayer de la pointées au loin
et utiliser le théorème de thalès pour
calculer la distance qui le sépare du
bateau je veux pas faire un détail cette
fois mais j'espère que je vous ai à peu
près convaincu que juste avec ces
données on est capable de calculer
ensuite le rayon de la terre et ça je
trouve injuste font qu'en observant des
bateaux s'éloigner pour qu'elle crée le
rayon de la terre c'est fou
mais cette méthode en pratique elle est
difficile à appliquer s'il ya un peu de
vent un petit peu de mirage un petit peu
de vagues
il ya plein de choses qui peuvent pas
être des très bonnes mesures
et du coup le calcul va être assez
approximatif et du coup le résultat
final bas risquent de varier son dos du
simple au double en faisant cette
méthode
en tout cas ça n'a pas été la méthode la
plus fiable de la mesure du rayon de la
terre l'autre méthode de calcul du rayon
de la terre est due à un certain
eratosthène or l'histoire d'un rat la
toscane est juste incroyable
ce mec en fait ce qu'il a fait c'est
qu'un jour ils veulent aller à sour et
puis ils voient le puits il a le regard
de ba dupuy je dis tant mieux le bas du
puits et éclairé alors que le puits est
assez verticale
du coup si le bas du public est clair
c'est que le soleil l'éclair directement
de haut en bas
le soleil est à la verticale autrement
dit un rayon du soleil c'est le
continuel il ira jusqu'au centre de la
terre
et là il s'est dit alors en fait il
suffit que je calcule un seul autre
angle et une distance et je connaîtrai
le rayon de la terre pour ça que je
marche vers le nord du coup il a marché
vers le nord tila march et 1000 km en
fait d'adapter lui-même quand quelqu'un
pour le faire
cette personne aussi lui a demandé de
comptes et c'est pas faux fait de
compter la distance fatick n'était pas
là ces personnalités pas ses propres pas
et compter les pas d'un syndrome adhère
pourquoi un dromadaire parce que
dromadaires on n'est pas très régulier
bref ce qui est fou c'est que au bout de
la distance
il avait une bonne estimation de la
distance entre a souvent et alexandrie
et atteint cette nuit quand il est
arrivé à alexandrie il a planté un bâton
au sol façon bien verticale sorky un
angle droit avec le sol et il va
regarder quelle était la longueur de
l'ombre tout ça pour calculer l'ongle
que formaient le rayon soleil la
direction du rayon de soleil avec la
verticale et du coup avec un petit h de
vent et s'est dit que cet angle là qui
est du coup assez facile à calculer
en fait c'était le même que l'angle
entre alexandrie et assouan vue du
centre de la terre
stand g nicole donc septembre qui valait
à peu près tout sur 50 c'est à dire un
cinquantième de tours ça veut dire que
s'il avait fait 50 fois de distance
entre à suez et alexandrie et mais il
aura fait le tour de la terre donc
cinquante fois sa distance à distance là
et à peu près 1000 km bailat il y en a
conclu que la circonférence de la terre
le tour de la terre faisait à peu près
50 mille kilomètres ce qui est vraiment
pas mal quoi voir evra ont vraiment pas
la valeur qu'il aura calcul est plutôt
dans les ordres de 45 mille kilomètres
encore mieux que ce que venir puisque la
vraie circonférence de la terre et 40000
km et des brouettes fait pendant
quelques années c'était 40000 km fait ça
devait être 48 km comme l explique
viviane sur syllabus mais bon ils ont
fait de la merde dans la mesure de la
circonférence de la terre
au xviiie siècle par la merde ça aurait
été très très bon mais on fait pour lui
désormais politique c'est un petit peu
galère vous raconte pas tout histoire
allait voir s'il abuse si vous êtes tus
radio y aussi un peu de patience sur ce
sujet et donc les grecs déjà savait que
la terre était ronde il a même calculé
avec une très très bonne précision la
taille de la terre
du coup c'est assez marrant de lire que
christophe colomb a été plus malin que
les autres en pensant que l'uja terre
était ronde et rock les autres le savent
pas en fête tombe de saint vaast
l'époque et même tout le monde savait
quelle était la taille de la terre
en fait tout le sait sauf christophe
conquis lui craint et croyait que la
terre était plus petit que ça qu'elle ne
l'est et c'est pour ça que lui croyait
qu'il était possible d'aller jusqu'en
inde en passant par l'atlantique
manque de bol c'est un petit peu plus
loin coup de bol il y avait quelque
chose au milieu
heureusement et pourtant ça n'empêche
pas des gens aujourd'hui encore de
prétendre que la terre est plate
une société américaine qui s'appelle la
flat earth society qui prétend que la
terre est plate et ce qui est marrant
c'est que avec ce postulat il arrive
quand même à expliquer de façon un peu
haddock pas mal de trucs que l'on voit
par exemple pouvoir faire la remarque
qui cause de la gravité
tous les objets finissent par s'aplatir
de partout et pas trop ont surtout s'ils
ont la taille de la terre du coup la
terre ne peut pas être plate à caussens
gravité qui force les objets être rond
l'explication qu'ils avancent c'est
qu'en fait la gravité n'existe pas que
la terre est plate et elle accélère vers
le haut à dix mètres par seconde carrés
est en fait tout ce qu'on croit être la
gravité n'est que l'accès à peut-être
pas si bête
ils ont aussi les explications ad-hoc
pour eratosthène et les bateaux qui
passent l'horizon notamment pour un
toast est finie c'est qu'en fait le
soleil est beaucoup plus petit que ceux
qu'on croit et beaucoup plus près de la
terre en fait ils bougent dans le ciel
et c'est le fait qu'ils bougent dans le
ciel qui explique que
nombreux médias comme quelqu'un qui lui
observe carrément le fait que la terre
est plate et selon lui la terre est
plate et en fait ça paraît si con à dire
mais sans vrai que pour la plupart des
gens la terre est en fait plate et quand
je parle de la plupart des gens je parle
pas de la plupart des humains de la
plupart des aliens parce que la plupart
des aliens avance à la vitesse
faramineuse compagnon instruction le
bout de l'univers avance les vitesses
proches de vitesse de la lumière si ce
n'est plus vite qualité et lumière par
rapport à nous du coup si venez nous
voir s'ils étaient dans l'incapacité de
venir nous voir
ce serait à la vitesse quasiment de la
lumière ou quelque chose comme ça ce
fric on voit la vitesse quasiment celle
de la lumière
la terre s'aplatit c'est celle fuchs et
einstein qui l'a dit c'est golden tandis
que pour tous les objets qui vont super
vite
les distances dans leur direction de
mouvements se réduisent du coup en
particulier pour les hommes chez qui
montrait très vite pour les gens qui
vont très vite pour les aliens qui
voyagent à la vitesse proche de la
lumière et en particulier pour les
particules cosmiques
qu'ils aillent sur la terre à des
vitesses proche c'est la lumière la
terre est plate
tout l'univers est plein en fait fait
point photons l'univers entier et plats
pas juste la terre tout l'univers est
plat complètement plat pour un photon
pour le coup il met 0 secondes lui le
foot on pour aller d'un point à l'autre
le monde est plat pour le photon et
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
alors vous n'avez peut-être pas tout à
fait compris mon petit délire sur
l'histoire du photon si c'est le cas ça
tombe de super bien puisque la vidéo que
vous venez de regarder fait partie d'une
série de vidéos si vous souhaitez un peu
perspicace et que vous
le titre ça fait partie d'une série de
vidéos que je fais sur les théories de
la relativité nourrit l'autorité
restreinte et général par albert
einstein et d'ailleurs la prochaine
vidéo de cette série est justement sur
la théorie de la relativité restreinte
nous verrons pour parler de cette
contraction des distances et je vous
invite aussi à réfléchir à la nonna
d'itv td vitesse dont j'ai parlé dans
l'épisode précédent fait je vous invite
même à essayer de réfléchir à toutes les
conséquences que tout ça peut avoir
comment est ce qu'on peut ajouter un
formalisme autour du tout ça essayer de
voir quels sont les paradoxes qui ont
l'air de surgir et comment les résoudre
et en fait si vous faites ça vous aurait
fait ce qu einstein a fait en 1905 à
lorsqu'il a posé les fondements de la
théorie de l'ordre était restreint dont
on va donc parler dans la prochaine
vidéo en tout cas je vous invite à liker
partager commenter cette vidéo et
j'espère que je vous verrai la prochaine
fois j'ai pas dire particulière avec la
rue moi le combat est réglée depuis
longtemps un me d'eratosthène ce qu'il a
fait si c'est pas la définition exacte
d'un génie alors d'où vient cette erreur
de 0,2 me